the big picture question here I guess is
how much credit should warn buff and get
for the increased prevalence of IUDs and
family planning in the US so his family
foundation the susan thompson Buffett
foundation which was named after his
first wife has become by far the most
prominent donor supporting expanding
access and research into IUDs they
really began a big push right around
2007 what happened in a series of a
couple years of Warren's first wife
Susan Thompson Buffett passed away and
left the majority of her wealth 2.5
billion dollars to the foundation and
then at the same time Warren did the big
donation that he made of his his wealth
he left most of it to the Gates
Foundation but still gave what at the
time was a million b shares in Berkshire
Hathaway to the foundation to play out
over time and so all of a sudden the
foundation came into a huge amount of
money that I had to spend because
foundations have to spend five percent
of their their their assets used here
and so they began aggressively funding
iud research so so they have become the
largest force really trying to
reestablish IUDs as a safe and desirable
form of contraception and they did so in
swing states through the choice project
I'm sorry to cut it so short but it's a
fabulous story Karen thank you so much
for your time Reid Karen's story it is
the cover story of Bloomberg
Businessweek it is out on shelves
tomorrow it is on the web today how
warren buffett's Family Foundation
secretly funded a revolution in birth
control here in the US pick up Karen's
story